[Music]  i think  the smartest people in the world  are people who are going to be looking  to invest in africa  africa as a whole is really very well  known as a resource  rich environment  [Music]  we knew nothing about the restaurant  business and my original intention was  really to do it as part of like a  pure investment we're able to digitize  that we're able to create  algorithms because we have data spanning  30 years  there's been a lot of evolvement or  transformation  very micro businesses becomes more small  businesses become  medium medium become large enterprises  and large enterprises are corporatizing  [Music]  you can't keep pointing fingers and  saying someone's going to come and save  the day  you have to in your own way figure out a  way to lead and let  others join you or assist you but be  part of that solution  [Music]  they are in the driver's seat we're just  empowering them to change their lives  [Music]  you